[Music]
in 2019
i served as deputy policy director for a
presidential
campaign working on a campaign is insane
and thrilling imagine a startup on
steroids
where reporters watch every move
you're racing towards a stressful
deadline
called election day each staffer is
responsible for a massive
amount of work and lots of work is done
by volunteers
i started as an unpaid advisor after
several months i became the first
full-time policy lead my job involved
building a team briefing the candidate
and developing plans for dozens
of issues one issue the candidate deeply
cared about
was racial equity one night the campaign
leadership called
they said hey we want a racial justice
plan to be our first
major release can you take it on
i had such mixed feelings about leading
this effort
i'd never directly experienced racism
i thought i don't know the solutions and
thinking that i do
would be so presumptuous
but this was also a chance to use my
power
to do something as a white person
it is my responsibility to fight for
racial justice
over generations my family and i have
benefited
from racism so it's absolutely
on us to help fix it
the question was how how could i design
an
equitable process could the campaign
have a real
impact so even if we lost we could push
other candidates to think bigger
i'm here to share five lessons i learned
from this process lesson one
make time i want to give you a sense of
how policies
often develop on campaigns campaigns can
assign an issue to whomever has time
and the staffer will write a few pages
of high-level points
or they'll copy and paste research from
a think tank
outsource to an expert or play it safe
and not release anything
but when it comes to racial justice we
needed to make time
when everyone is busy it's easy to avoid
the hardest work
so we started spending less time on
other projects to make room for this one
and plan for lots more calls with the
candidate
i had no idea how this process would go
but to do it right we needed to make
time
lesson two more voices
to create an equitable process i figured
we'd need a lot of voices involved
i'm grateful that two rock stars agreed
to help
nina smith was our traveling press
secretary and jose
morales our national constituency
director
they're both people of color with
backgrounds in policy
and government and they share many of
the lived and intersectional experiences
with the people we hoped to serve with
the plan
then we invited other extraordinary
experts
to join us porsha on civil rights
aaron on housing chike on
entrepreneurship
ashwin and andres on health and many
others
they are inspiring leaders of color
deeply
committed to these issues led by their
vision
together we set our sights high
we wanted to develop a plan as bold as
the marshall plan
that rebuilt europe after the second
world war
our goal a road map to dismantle
centuries
of racist systems across society
lesson three listen
then we had to get to work and actually
write a bold plan
the team started listening to so many
people's stories
within a month we talked to over 60
activists
scholars and organizations
formerly incarcerated individuals
fighting to restore
their right to vote academics
studying the racial wealth gap even the
direct descendants
of frederick douglass the more we
listened we heard creative ideas
and we saw our gaps for example we
talked to leaders in flint michigan as
they rebounded from the water crisis
it became clear we needed to be a lot
stronger
on environmental justice so we added
policies like
equitable disaster relief and making
sure the epa
considers environmental justice in all
of its decisions
listen broadly deeply
and with humility
lesson four stay engaged
this work can feel daunting systemic
racism runs
so deep across our institutions and
policies
the kinds of solutions we were seeking
were how to attack the racial wealth gap
reduce incarceration pass health policy
grounded
in anti-racism the more the scale of
these challenges sunk in the more i
realized that
i needed to stay engaged
it's easy to go vote protest
every once in a while and then turn away
staying engaged also meant educating
myself
sitting in meetings i realized wow there
is so much history
i'm missing so late at night i do deeper
dives on
redlining cash bail reparations
and many other issues our experts were
bringing to the table
to be an ally i needed to stay engaged
and constantly educate myself
lesson five be accountable
lots of organizations release diversity
and inclusion plans
they make commitments but what is the
plan
for accountability in our case it meant
making sure that racial equity was a
huge part of
every plan for example our disability
policy
was laser focused on equity
we addressed school suspension rates
voter suppression
unemployment all of these
disproportionately impact
people of color with disabilities
but as hard as we tried to center racial
equity
there were plenty of times i could have
done better
for example at the beginning of the
campaign i tracked diversity across
our volunteer teams i wanted to ensure
equitable recruitment and participation
but when i got busy i fell behind on
this effort
it's easy to stop following through
when we're crushed with work it's easy
to get discouraged when we get called
out
or make a mistake but there is no excuse
allyship isn't a mindset
it's actually doing the work
we ended up naming our platform the
frederick douglass plan
a comprehensive investment in the
empowerment
of black america and by we i mean the
dozens of leaders of color who drove
this vision
while there were lots of reactions to
the plan it shared bold ideas and
spotlighted racial justice as a campaign
priority i hold on to one reaction from
none other than
stacy abrams who said the douglas plan
should be
front and center in 2020
and beyond sure our candidate lost
but other candidates adopted our
recommendations
some were even carried out on day one of
the biden administration
so why am i sharing
this story of my learning process
because i want all of us to show up
for racial equity as you move into
senior roles your leadership especially
matters
our generation is facing so many complex
challenges
we need to think about racial equity as
we tackle problems
from climate change to income inequality
so let's make time
let's bring in more voices let's
listen and stay engaged
and let's hold ourselves accountable
otherwise the cracks in our democratic
project will keep growing
moving forward let's be as bold
and transformational as this
moment demands us to be
[Applause]
[Music]